das ist wirklich eine spektakuläre
entdeckung internationaler astronomie
teams haben nämlich zwei
gammastrahlenausbrüche aufgespürt die
noch energiereicher strahlen als bislang
bekannt sie besitzen achtung rund 100
milliarden mal mehr energie als
sichtbares licht bau es handelt sich
also um einen kosmischen gamma blitz
rekord der zum ersten mal überhaupt mit
hilfe von erdgebundenen gammastrahlen
teleskopen nachgewiesen werden konnte
und es ist ziemlich verblüffend wie
diese gammablitze zu ihrer wahnsinnigen
energie kommen tricks um science-fiction
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
schon ende der 60er jahre wurde das
super spannende kosmische phänomene der
gamma ray burst grb es entdeckt es
handelt sich um kurze plötzliche
ausbrüche von gammastrahlung im kosmos
die gammablitze selbst entstehen wenn
neutronensterne kollidieren und außerdem
wohl auch bei supernovaexplosionen von
riesensonnen die zu einem schwarzen loch
kollabieren die konkreten prozesse sind
allerdings noch nicht in allen details
verstanden dazu der astronom david
berger vom deutschen elektronen
synchrotron desy in hamburg gammablitze
sind die stärksten bekannten explosionen
dem universum und setzten typischerweise
in wenigen sekunden mehr energie frei
als unsere sonne ihrer gesamten
lebensdauer sie können durch nahezu das
gesamte sichtbare universum leuchten
dennoch sind die gammastrahlenausbrüche
bislang nicht mit erdgebundenen
teleskopen zu beobachten da die
erdatmosphäre die gamma quanten der
blitze schluckt somit blieb
forschungsteams weltweit bislang nichts
anderes übrig als die spektakulären
gammastrahlenausbrüche mit hilfe von
satelliten vom erd orbit aus zu
analysieren doch jetzt gelang eine
spannende premiere zwei internationale
astronomenteams konnten nämlich
erstmalig gammastrahlung von gamma ray
burst mit erdgebundenen teleskopen
nachweisen und zwar einmal am 20 juli
2018 durch das gamma strahlen teleskop
des high energy stereoscopic system pss
in namibia und zum anderen mitte januar
2009 10 durch das major atmospheric
imaging cherenkov magic teleskop auf la
palma dies gelang mit einem trick denn
die spezial teleskopen beobachten
direkt die kosmischen gamma quanten
sondern deren wirkung auf die
erdatmosphäre
denn letztendlich entsteht ein
bläuliches leuchten wenn energiereiche
kosmische gamma quanten auf die
erdatmosphäre treffen es ist
vergleichbar mit dem überschallknall
allerdings handelt es sich bei dem
leuchtend natürlich um ein optisches
phänomen das kommt zustande weil die
gamma quanten moleküle und atome in der
erdatmosphäre zerschmettern und somit
eine lawine von folge teilchen auslösen
in der fachsprache ist von einem
sogenannten luft schauer die rede der
sich dann schneller durch die luft
bewegt als licht sich in diesem medium
bewegen kann
die lichtgeschwindigkeit wird also
trotzdem nicht überschritten so entsteht
dann also das bläuliche leuchten dass
die forschenden als tschernjakow licht
bezeichnen und genau das ist mit hilfe
der spezial teleskope der gss und magic
observatorien zu beobachten was anfangen
dieser beiden gammablitze erfolgt der
übrigen nachdem die beiden nasa
satelliten swift und fermi diese als
erster registriert hatten und dann
alarmmeldungen automatisiert an weitere
opfer geschickt hatten doch nicht nur
die art und weise wie diese gammablitze
nun aufgespürt werden konnten sind
einmalig und rekordverdächtig beide
gammastrahlenausbrüche sind nämlich
weitaus stärker als alle die zuvor
beobachtet werden konnten bei dem einen
ausbruch mit der bezeichnung grb 19 0 11
4 c erreichten die gammastrahlen einer
energie von 200 bis 1000 milliarden
elektronenvolt dazu elisabeth die vom
bsi dies sind bei weitem die höchsten
energetischen photonen die jemals von
einem gemma ray burst entdeckt worden
sind und auch beim anderen ereignisse
mit der bezeichnung grb 18 0 72 sorry
wenn ich hier englisch und deutsch müsse
aber geht schneller wurden extrem starke
energiebereiche von 100 bis 400
milliarden elektronenvolt registriert
und das nicht nur auf dem höhepunkt des
ausbruchs sondern zehn stunden danach
dabei hatte der strahlen fluss zu diesem
zeitpunkt schon um vier größenordnung
abgenommen diese beobachtung ist für die
fachleute selbst eine große überraschung
denn bislang konnte immer nur beobachtet
werden dass die gammastrahlen nach
wenigen minuten abflauen
bei diesem
nach grün war die strahlung bei den
bisherigen beobachtungen typischerweise
immer in eine längere wellenlängen
übergegangen wie also sind die rekord
gammablitze zu erklären
die forschungsteams gehen von einem
zweistufigen prozess aus bei dem es
einen zusatzschub durch
teilchenkollisionen gibt konkret zeigen
die neuen beobachtung dass die
sogenannte synchrotronstrahlung eine
entscheidende rolle bei den vorgängen
der gammastrahlenausbrüche spielt doch
die strahlen energie von gia wie 19 04 c
und d 18 0 27 b ist zu hoch um sie
alleine mit dieser strahlung zu erklären
sie entsteht wenn elektronen in starken
magnetfeldern stark beschleunigt werden
beispielsweise in der schockwelle einer
supernova die fachleute sehen deswegen
einen weiteren prozess als entscheidend
an
in der fachsprache ist vom sogenannten
in wersen konnten effekt die rede
hierbei erfolgt eine beschleunigung von
elektronen wodurch synchrotronstrahlung
entsteht doch durch kollisionen geben
die elektronen in einem weiteren schritt
energie an die photonen ab diese
bekommen somit einen weiteren schub und
erreichen damit energie im tera
elektronenvolt bereich dazu die
astronomen konstanz jahr sattlecker vom
dsi in dem wir festgestellt haben dass
gamma ray burst photonen mit energie
produzieren die 100 milliarden fach
höher sind als das sichtbare licht
wissen wir jetzt auch dass sie in der
lage sind artikel innerhalb der
explosionswolke hoch effizient zu
beschleunigen außerdem stellt sich
heraus dass uns bisher etwa die hälfte
ihres energie bee gees entgangen ist
wenn unsere messungen zeigen dass die im
bereich der sehr energiereichen
gammastrahlung freigesetzte energie
vergleichbar ist mit der energie die bei
allen anderen wellenlängen zusammen
abgestrahlt wird das ist bemerkenswert
die fachleute vom de selbst bezeichnen
ihre beobachtung als zitat bahnbrechend
und sie sind optimistisch dass ihr
verständnis von kameras dadurch enorm
verbessert werden kann groß und liegt
dabei auf dem gamma strahlen auf sagt
der nächsten generation es geht um das
geplante trainieren kopf telescope array
city mit dem bis zu zehn solcher
ereignisse pro jahr beobachtet werden
könnten es soll es mehr als 100 einzeln
teleskopen bestehen die an je einem
standort auf der nord und der süd
halbkugel aufgebaut werden wird ein
gamma blitz die erde zerstören
der hellste blitz aller zeiten das ist
das erste video von pixum science
fiction überhaupt also superspannend
anklicken anschauen um klicks um
science-fiction abonnieren wenn nicht
jetzt wann dann
bis dann bleibt dran